>>> WE WANT TO TAKE YOU TO
GUATEMALA CITY NOW WHERE U.S.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS IS
MEETING WITH THE GUATAMALAN
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS VIDEO FROM JUST MOMENTS
AGO.
HAVE A LOOK.
THE VICE PRESIDENT TOLD THE
GUATEMALAN PRESIDENT THAT IT WAS
IN THEIR COLLECTIVE INTEREST TO
WORK TOGETHER, ADDING IT WAS
CLEAR THE U.S. HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO COOPERATE AND
WORK WITH ALLIES.
THE U.S. VICE PRESIDENT IS ON A
FACT-FINDING MISSION TO FIND OUT
WHY SO MANY PEOPLE LEAVE THEIR
HOMES IN LATIN AMERICA FOR THE
DANGEROUS TRIP TO THE UNITED
STATES.
WHAT KAMALA HARRIS LEARNS COULD
REALLY HELP CRAFT U.S.
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
SHE'S MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF GUATEMALA.
HER NEXT STOP IS MEXICO WHERE
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN SUNDAY'S
MIDTERM ELECTION.
THERE'S A LOT TO UNPACK.
JEREMY DIAMOND IS FOLLOWING THE
TRIP.
MATT RIVERS IS IN MEXICO.
JEREMY, LET'S START WITH THAT
MEETING THAT TOOK PLACE SHORTLY
BETWEEN THE GUATAMALAN PRESIDENT
AND KAMALA HARRIS.
TALK TO US WHAT KICAME OUT OF TT
STATEMENT THAT WE BRIEFLY SAW
AND WHAT KAMALA HARRIS IS TRYING
TO GET TO THE HAREART OF DURING
HER VISIT.
>> Reporter: WELL, RIGHT OUT THE
GATE YOU HEARD HER TALKING ABOUT
MIGRATION IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE ON THE TABLE BETWEEN THE
TALKS BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES
AND GUATEMALA.
OF COURSE, THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION IS REALLY THE FOCUS OF
HER VISIT, AND THOSE FACTORS ARE
MANY.
YOU HAVE EVERYTHING FROM POVERTY
TO HUNGER, CLIMATE CHANGE, AND
CRIME AND THE DICEY ISSUE OF
CORRUPTION.
WE HAVEN'T YET HEARD VERY MUCH
FROM INSIDE THAT ROOM IN TERMS
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE VICE
PRESIDENT IS ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE OF CORRUPTION, BUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW IS HER ADVISERS HAVE
MADE CLEAR THEY SEE CORRUPTION
IN GUATEMALA AND OTHERS AS
ENDEMIC AND AS ONE OF THE
PRIMARY ROOT CAUSES THAT PUSHES
PEOPLE TO LEAVE THEIR HOMES IN
GUATEMALA AND MIGRATE THROUGH
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HEARD THE VICE PRESIDENT TALK
ABOUT THE FACT SHE'S TRYING TO
WORK TO BRING HOPE TO THE
REGION.
THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING HER
ADVISERS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED AHEAD
OF THESE MEETINGS.
INDEED IT'S THAT HOPELESSNESS
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE FEEL HERE
THAT PUSHES THEM TO MIGRATE TO
THE UNITED STATES DESPITE THE
DANGEROUS JOURNEY THEY FACE,
DESPITE THE PROSPECTS ONCE THEY
ARRIVE IN THE U.S.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE DESPERATION
THAT THEY'RE FACING HERE,
WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
DEVASTATING HURRICANES THAT
DESTROYED SO MUCH -- SO MANY
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS, THE
DROUGHT THAT HAS AFFECTED
FARMERS IN THE RURAL PARTS OF
GUATEMALA.
THERE ARE MANY, MANY ISSUES
HERE.
WE WILL SEE HOW THE VICE
PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO ENGAGE ON
THIS TODAY.
HER TEAM HAS SUGGESTED THERE
WILL BE POLICY DELIVERABLES
TODAY, VERY CLEAR DECISIONS
BEING MADE, ONE OF THE
ANTI-CORRUPTION FRONT AND ONE ON
THE CENTRAL AMERICAN MIGRANTS
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY WILL BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR ASYLUM AND GET TO THE UNITED
STATES.
WE'LL SEE WHETHER THERE IS
ACTUALLY PROGRESS MADE ON THAT.
LASTLY THE THING I WOULD NOTE IS
THE PRESID
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS NOT ONLY
FOCUSING ON THE GUATAMALAN
GOVERNMENT.
SHE'S GOING TO BE MEETING WITH
YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS AND CIVIL
SOCIETY.
THAT SHOWS THEY ARE NOT THE ONLY
SHOW IN TOWN.
THEY NEED TO WORK GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT, BUT THE UNITED
STATES CAN WORK TO TRY TO
ADDRESS ISSUES LIE CORRUPTION
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT WILL NOT.
>> JEREMY, DO STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO BRING IN MATT RIVERS
IN MEXICO.
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
ELECTIONS, BUT REALLY YOU'VE
SPOKEN TO SO MANY MIGRANTS WHO
HAVE MADE IT TO THE UNITED
STATES.
AS KAMALA HARRIS TRIES TO GET TO
THE HEART OF WHY SO MANY ARE
LEAVING, WHICH IS, YOU KNOW,
CORRUPTION AND POVERTY, AND THE
CORRUPTION, IF YOU START WITH EL
SALVADOR OR HONDURAS, IT'S NOT
SOMETHING YOU CAN DO OVERNIGHT.
IT'S A LONG-TERM FIGHT.
TELL US HOW HARD OF A TASK THIS
WILL BE FOR THE UNITED STATES.
>> Reporter: YOU CAN'T PUT A
FINE ENOUGH POINT ON THAT, ISA.
IT'S A GREAT POINT THAT YOU
BRING UP HERE.
THE UNITED STATES HAS AN
IMMEDIATE ISSUE RIGHT NOW, WHICH
IS A HUGE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
ARRIVING AT THE U.S. SOUTHERN
BORDER.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, THOSE ARE
LONG-TERM SOLUTIONS.
SO HOW DOES THE UNITED STATES
MANAGE TO GIVE PEOPLE AS ONE
ANALYST I SPOKE TO ENOUGH HOPE
THAT THAT BY STAYING IN THEIR
COUNTRY THEIR LIVES WILL GET
BETTER.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE A REASON
TO STAY.
PEOPLE ARE NOT LEAVING BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO, BECAUSE THIS IS AN
EASY JOURNEY.
HONDURAS, GAT MA RAH, NICARAGUA,
EL SALVADOR, PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
FOR SURVIVAL.
THESE TRIPS ARE INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
NOTHING AT HOME, THERE ARE NO
JOBS, THERE'S GANG VIOLENCE,
GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION, AND
PEOPLE ARE LIVING ON DOLLARS A
DAY, THEY DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM.
IT'S EITHER MIGRATING OR
LITERALLY STARVE.
OVER THE PAST YEAR GIVEN THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC AND THE TWO
DEVASTATING HURRICANES THEY HAD
BACK TO BACK CATEGORY 4
HURRICANES, IT'S MADE THE ISSUES
SO UNTENABLE.
YOU CAN WORK WITH CIVIL SOCIETY
AND THE NGO.
LOOK AT WHAT THE U.S. HAS TO
WORK WITH.
IN ELSALVADOR, YOU HAVE A
RISING DICTATOR.
THE PRESIDENT OF HONDURAS IS AN
UNINDAYLIGHTED CO-CONSPIRATOR
WITH HIS BROTHER WHO WAS
OFFICIALLY INDICTED AND CHARGED
AND FOUND GUILTY IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR NARCO-TRAFFICKING.
TO SUMMARIZE THAT, ISA, THIS IS
NOT AN EASY SOLUTION FOR THE
UNITED STATES TO HAVE TO FIGURE
THIS OUT.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS A VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TASK AHEAD OF HER.
>> IN GUATEMALA, THERE'S
CORRUPTION IN COURTS WITH
JUDGES.
THANK YOU.
I WISH WE HAD MORE TIME, MATT.
I COU